I wanted to say you were talking about
like you guys growing up you were also
growing up in a culture where there were
not that many famous people so famous
people were gigantic and now we live in
a world where you know you have
influencers our daughters you know on
social media and I think it's really
important and one of the messaging with
this film is like you can you can do all
your fun stuff on social media but don't
turn yourself into a product which is so
easy to do in this day and age you know
what I mean and have who you are as a
person be your strength but also when
they ask kids you know if you ask kids
today like what do you want to be they
say famous
it's not like oh I want to be an actress
or I want to be a this no they want to
be famous and like that that sort of
Disconnect is so dangerous it's so
dangerous and it's coveting the wrong
things